countless visitors flocked to New York
City's Madison Square Park to gaze upon
and take selfies with some of the
world's most famous buildings but even
native New Yorkers probably miss one of
the most interesting stories in the
city's skyline located in here and
that's because most of it doesn't exist
during the major economic expansion of
New York City in the late 19th and early
20th centuries demand and prices for
prime real estate in Manhattan soared
thanks to advancements in construction
and elevator technology developers could
suddenly build vertically to increase
useable space essentially creating land
in the sky skyscrapers as these mega
projects were called started popping up
in the priciest parts of the city often
named after the companies that funded
their construction in a clever form of
brand marketing in the latter half of
the rori 1920s the Metropolitan Life
Insurance Company wanted to construct a
new skyscraper to house its growing
staff alongside its existing landmark
headquarters on 24th Street the
ambitious plan called for the tallest
building in the world at the time around
a hundred stories incorporating the
distinctive setback look that was
required by New York City's recently
adopted zoning code there was one
problem however during the same week of
the plans being announced the US stock
market had collapsed signaling the end
of the roaring 20s and the beginning of
the Great Depression with funding scaled
back the grand design
much like the decade of excess in which
it was conceived was cut off eventually
topping out at barely a third of the
height of the previous design leaving
behind a stump that some might say is a
monument to economic hubris fast-forward
to today and New York City skyline is
again dotted with impressive and
record-breaking skyscrapers many nearing
completion as the global economy
sputters some economists insists the
timing of these skyscraper booms and
economic downturns is more than just
coincidence in fact some have called it
the skyscraper curse this is mark
Thornton who in 2007 applied an economic
model called the skyscraper index to
suggest that the construction of the
world's tallest building the bourse
Khalifa in Dubai meant that a global
financial crisis was coming which it did
a year or so later the model he used is
based on an idea proposed in 1999 by a
real estate analyst named Andrew
Lawrence he looked at all the
record-setting skyscrapers beginning
with a singer building in New York City
true was correlated with the panic of
1907 and then you go to the late 1920s
and you see the Chrysler Building and
the Empire State Building setting
records consecutively and then of course
the crash of 29 and then you fast
forward until you get to 1970 when world
trade tower one world trade tower - and
the Sears building all set new records
and then of course we had the long
stagflation of the 1970s fast forward
from that you get new record study
skyscrapers in the late 1990s and early
2000s and of course right in the middle
of that was the tech stock bubble bust
you know the correlations holding up
very well and some see those warning
signs on the rise again entrepreneurs
did great
everybody was making money for so long
but what we're gonna see is that there's
gonna be this cluster of errors where
companies have to cut back retrench go
bankrupt foreclose
we're certainly not looking forward to
it in a sense of being a joyful event
but the skyscraper index is to put it
lightly controversial no offense to you
but this guy's never occurs I really
wish we would put this to bed this is
Jason Barr an economist and author who
specializes in what he calls sky na
mcc's and he co-authored an empirical
analysis of the skyscraper index and
found that it's example of what I call
broken clock ISM okay
if you're looking to pair a skyscraper
boo
with a downturn it's easy because the
downturns are happening all the time you
could just say oh here's the peak of the
skyscraper cycle oh here's the business
cycle oh yeah they must be connected in
some way
although bars research called into
question the forecasting potential of
record-breaking skyscrapers it did
confirm that skyscraper construction
waves typically rise when economic
conditions are favorable sometimes to
the point of a bubble and then slow as
the project's make less financial sense
and funding dries up much like the case
of the Metropolitan Life North Building
kind of are hurting mentality when the
getting's good everybody all these
developers they rush to get their
buildings online as soon as possible and
then you know you have a glut you
conceive of a project based on the
economics today and then when it comes
online four or five years from now
anything could happen in other words
skyscrapers simply take a long time to
build and some end up being completed
after the next downturn has already
begun this timing if anything is more
like a lagging indicator than a leading
one I guess I just wish this guys
grabber curse thing would people would
stop using it because there's zero
evidence that it actually exists but
what makes something like the skyscraper
Index so alluring in the first place
well for one unlike many other economic
indicators like consumer price indices
and unemployment rates or GDP
skyscrapers are so visible they are
super visible they're ultra visible I
mean the skyline is the very notion and
identity of the city in a lot of ways
skyscrapers are um a marvel of
technology I mean when you think about
symbols of civilization a skyscraper is
one of them but ultimately skyscrapers
are simply products of our economic
system or a skyscraper historian Carol
Willis has called them the ultimate
architecture of capitalism fundamentally
skyscrapers are a part of a larger story
of human urbanization though all the
forces that draws two cities create this
need to build offices and high-rise
buildings that accommodate all of these
people who want to be
same place at the same time this demand
for access to urban space has fueled a
global skyscraper boom during the past
decade and according to the skyscraper
Center database over 130 super tall
construction projects are currently
underway worldwide but his social
distancing and remote work call into
question the demand for dense urban life
skyscrapers may be taking on an entirely
new meaning after all if a full busy
skyscraper can represent power and
prosperity an unfinished or empty one
can stand in for economic transition hey
you know Detroit economic crisis of the
1960s 1970s we saw it for a long time
skyscrapers with with very little value
I don't think there's any indication yet
that we can expect us on some mass scale
across the United States but at the same
time the ravages of kovat 19 are totally
unchecked so it's very hard to predict
the full economic consequences of what's
happening as always the future remains
to be seen but one thing does seem
likely
if this skyscraper boom does come to an
end as the economy shifts don't be
surprised if some say the curse may be
striking again
[Music]
you